okay i think we can get started hi
i'm bob nockbar i'm in the wolfram
solutions department the consulting
department
of wolfram research and uh i've been
doing
some uh epidemiology modeling
for the kobit pandemic i
had a couple of community posts earlier
this spring
and we had some twitch sessions where we
talked about our various efforts and
what i wanted to talk about today
was the extension of of some of those
uh earlier models that i had worked on
and so
here's the the abstract but what i want
to point out though
is a little bit of a spoiler um
well uh we did uh do some
some modeling with stratified uh models
over networks and some stochastic
modeling
as well a lot more needs to be done to
to really understand what they can
contribute to
uh modeling a pandemic an epidemic
outbreak
and so on um also when
we had to write our abstracts for the
conference which was several months ago
other developments have intervened and
i've learned some new things about
modeling these sorts of systems
and so i've adapted my uh work uh
in response to those uh that new
information
and so i'll be you know including some
of that in the presentation as well
so um the talk is really more about
methodology than applications because
uh basically i'm a tool builder i'm more
of a a craftsman than an artist you
might say
and uh so we'll we'll get through this
and i hope you
uh learn something from my talk and i
can stay on
as long as necessary afterwards for
questions and we can always follow up
later
okay so this is these are the
things i'm going to cover a little bit
of background and rationale
for why i needed to change the the
models i was working on
earlier a little bit of background on
compartmental models there have been
several talks
already at least two today um
on this topic uh people have talked
about non-pharmaceutical interventions
uh thomas most recently with his
government switch function
as it were um i'll describe
briefly a more realistic cart mental
compartmental model that i've
uh developed to better describe what's
actually
happening uh in the the covid uh
epidemic
i'll talk about network models network
topologies
and then how we distribute the
epidemiology model over a network
and then an example of doing that for uh
the italy and the uh
data for italy okay
so just quickly um
yes we want to initialize everything
we can load the data for italy from the
wolfram data repository
and here we are comes out as time series
and we can plot the data and this is the
the typical sort of curve we see of
those data the number of confirmed cases
over time
the number of deaths over time and the
number of recovered people over time
we see that uh the the pandemic
uh in in european countries and in north
america
began in march in china that was
beginning earlier in january and
february
we often want to convert these raw
numbers into something that is more
epidemiologically related or disease
related such as the prevalence
which is roughly the confirmed cases uh
less the
the number of people that have died in
the number of people that have recovered
and that's this curve here um
and then we've got the incidents which
is just the
the daily difference of the uh confirmed
cases
uh which is kind of like the derivative
of of the prevalence
and then the number of dead people
so we had done earlier work we were
looking at the data
from china and here
we can see that the outbreak occurred
much earlier at the time when i was
doing that
work uh late february early march these
were all the data that we had
and i was trying to model the data for
the province of hubei which has
58 million people and
i was having a very difficult time doing
that um
and somebody suggested that well they
were able to fit the data by reducing
the effect of population size
and i tried that and by reducing it to
500
000 or 100 000 thousand or fifty
thousand i got fits that were
better but still not good um
the recovered curves were generally in
the right position
but not the right slopes the
number of people that were infected
at the time the prevalence i i could get
it to go
roughly through the data but i couldn't
get it to turn
over properly and i was really not
happy with it they're they're really
unrealistic and if you look at the
parameter values that come out
from this curve fitting exercise they're
they're really
not uh uh appropriate from an
epidemiological point of view the the
r-naughts
are way too high they shouldn't really
be above 10.
um the infectious period is lasting way
too long
uh you know four months two months
um and and people just not dying at all
uh in this case here are just completely
unrealistic
so um we wanted to try some changes and
some of the things that i had looked at
was looking at stochastic modeling
and uh some preliminary work i had
gotten done on network modeling and that
seemed like
it it might be useful um
so let me just quickly make a very
simple seir
d model let me load the package for that
this is available on the cloud there's a
link at the end
of the presentation uh to that
and the way i define the models is i
just write a set of transitions
susceptible to exposed exposed to
infected
infected to recovered and infected to to
those that die and we can make a graph
of that
here showing the same steps and
we have a function called dynamic
transmission model
that basically takes the set of
transitions and then returns a number of
um data elements
that include among other things the
differential equations and the force of
infection
the force of infection comes in the
model here it's it's the
contact rate times the force of
infection and the force of infection is
essentially the number of infected
people
in this model here we're using standard
incidents
uh so we divide that by the total
population size
and uh we also reduce it by the number
of people that have died because they're
they're really removed
um and they shouldn't be included in the
computations after they
die we define the initial conditions
here we start out with everybody
being susceptible except for the number
of people that are infected
and a small number of infected people i
not
okay uh we can then define these
uh terms the outcomes the prevalence
the incidents uh we have a function
called incidence that takes the
the data from the model uh we tell it
which compartments
uh are in uh infectious so we can or
uh that are uh sick i should say and it
gives us the
the appropriate term for the rate at
which they appear and then the mortality
which are the people that die
okay we need to parameterize the model
what we want to do
is do that in terms of our naught
instead of of the the contact rate
what's nice about using our naught is
that we have a threshold for it
where we know if it's above one the
epidemic is going to persist and if it's
less than one it will be less than that
we use the next generation matrix method
to compute are not
and for this model here it has this
expression
uh very much similar to what thomas was
showing it is the recovery rate
um uh uh
well arnott is is essentially um the
contact rate divided by the recovery
rate but we've got some
uh modifications to it due to deaths in
the model
and uh that we've got uh a reduced
incidence because of the deaths and we
define some parameters
that we'll need and we convert them all
to numeric for simulation
and
screen's not showing me everything that
it's supposed to so i hope i don't miss
something
uh we need to know when the infection
first occurred in italy
and wikipedia reported
that january 31st uh there were two
chinese tourists that tested positive
so we can set that for our first
infection date
and the time horizon will extend up
through today
and if we look at the results these are
the data that we're actually observed
and if we use the full population size
in the model it's predicting that we're
going to see the big
uh
you know the infection is going to to
really take off in july and it's going
to
essentially hit most of the population
of italy
and this clearly did not happen um
and if we then
allow the population size to change
and if we slowly decrease this we can
see that the
the infection moves earlier in time
um but it still isn't matching the data
it's still not
not high enough um and by the time we
get it occurring
in march it's it's way too small and now
i've got the effect of population down
to ten thousand which is just totally
unrealistic
um and at this point uh i decided to
move on and start looking at other types
of of modeling
um for the pandemic instead of trying to
uh um
play around with this particular one and
try to you know
add add band-aids to it as it were
okay so one thing that we've recently
discovered is is very important
are these non-pharmaceutical
interventions uh
social distancing masks uh
government policies that uh cancel large
social events
um and things like that closing borders
restricting travel
and those sorts of things and they all
effectively reduce
the the contact rate um
and since the contact rate is
proportional to
the uh to our naught the basic
reproduction number
we can think about modulating r naught
instead of
modulating uh the contact rate itself
because this has a target
as i had said uh of one
above one the outbreak will persist and
below one it will dissipate which is
the goal okay so um
in uh italy uh
actually i should say uh uh in wuhan um
they
closed everything down in january
uh on january 23rd and the
first infection they estimated occurred
sometime around the 20th of december
so we can calculate um when that occurs
and we can use a very simple
function here that up until uh
january 23rd we've got the full force of
the infection
occurring and then it dissipates as
as people start social distancing as
people start getting quarantined when
they were sick and so on
and so um
yeah okay so when we use this model on
we incorporate this type of function
into the model
and use it on the wuhan data i can get a
better fit
to the data using the full population
size
our knot is still very high the death
rate is still way too low
the infectious period is still way too
long
so it's really just doing curve fitting
at this point and not really explaining
the disease very much
so let's let's move on from there
um i wanted to build a a more realistic
model than just a simple
scird because many other things were
going on
as far as people uh their health states
and how they were being treated
and and things like that the cdc has a
a website that has a fairly detailed
description
of uh the timeline of events that occur
so basically people get exposed about
six days
later symptoms show up they're often
tested by about the ninth day
after their initial infection if they
get hospitalized it occurs at a
different rate
depending on age older people tend to
get hospitalized sooner than younger
people
but the the average uh time is about 11
days after
uh exposure or at first infection
um they get released from the hospital
uh
from a non-icu setting at about 15 or 16
days
after infection um if they're
end up in the icu they get released
after about three weeks from
infection again very dependent on age
and death occurs at about three weeks um
and very dependent on on age
so i had a model um that included
three different infections compartments
asymptomatic mild and severe
two compartments to to model
hospitalized people
essentially they were quarantined if
they're in the hospital
not able to infect other people but
still being infected themselves
and i included three different uh
recovered compartments one for the
uh asymptomatic one for mild and one for
severe
and of course a death compartment as
well
these are the transitions so we'll
define
those we can make the model graph which
looks like this
these are the the quarantine
compartments here that are hospitalized
and the severely
infected people that become hospitalized
are in the ic unit and they're the ones
uh that
that generally
were able to succumb to the disease
and die also people that were severely
infected
but not hospitalized could also die in
this model
there are lots of variations on this
model this is not the only one
it's more than likely not perfect but it
will do for our purposes today so we can
define
all the components of the model
the differential equations and the force
of infection
and we set up the parameters we can
calculate
r naught and uh get
a relationship for beta from that and we
can define our parameters
notice here that i'm defining
essentially
times for things to happen incubation
time
time to go to the uh to get to the
hospital time to recover
time to be released from the hospital
released from icu and time to die
and from those i can then calculate the
rate constants
uh it makes it a little bit easier to uh
work with the the data we actually have
in hand
and then we can do a simulation
first we compute the initial conditions
as we did before
everybody's healthy except for a few
sick people
here and the first infection date was
reported to be january 31st so we set
that and the time horizon
we can do a differential equation
solution
and then compute the outcomes and we can
then see how the model compares against
the data
this is the model here and uh
with a simple um npi function that
basically
um has people um
you know social distancing and
restriction here and then a relaxation
of that
and they they start to go up again and
looking at it against the data we can
see that it does fairly well
i had uh optimized the um
a few of the parameters uh outside of
the notebook here
but are not uh the optimized value is
still way too high
and the the time that it takes to die is
very much on the high end it would be
better if it were
closer to the median so there's still
more work to do here
okay so i want to use this type of model
on a network
and see if uh spreading the
the people out as it were in different
communities
has uh a benefit in terms of modeling
we people don't always interact with
everybody else in the rest of their
country that's an unrealistic assumption
to make
um and so each vertex represents a
homogeneous community where
the typical seir type model
operates the edges between the vertices
represent migration of individuals
movement it's bi-directional
and uh the uh
network does not change over time in
terms of the number of connections
and the number of vertices that's static
some models allow
um the population the the network to to
evolve over time
and we're not doing that uh the
aggregate behavior of the the model
represents the aggregate epidemiology of
the whole country
and so that's what we really should
focus on and not the detailed results
within each community although those are
are interesting in their own right okay
so we have lots of different kinds of
models
i i wanted to start out modeling very
simple ones a very
well-defined structure to see if the
structure
of the of the networks has an effect
and these are very simple ones simple
linear ones cyclic ones
uh various types of um
planar layouts on a grid a rectangular
grid a trigonal grid a hexagonal grid or
just a random
planar network here you can see that the
degree
vertex degree uh histograms of these
very
the cyclic one all the nodes are the
same okay
and uh here we've got mostly uh
degree four nodes we've got some degree
three and a few degree two and so on
we can take these sorts of graphs and
make them more homogeneous by make
doing them essentially on a torus and
then all the vertices is the same they
always have a connectivity of four or a
connectivity of six
if we do them randomly on a sphere they
generally have a connectivity of six but
some have five and some have
seven um we can also do
what are called real world networks
using the barabasi
albert method or the watt strogatz
method
the the bare basey albert one tends to
have
a few nodes with very high connectivity
these are what we call hubs
most of the nodes have very small
connectivity and are connected to the
hubs
here for example here is a hub node and
we've got some hub nodes in there
the watts strogatz model is more like a
small world model
and the degree distribution is more even
most of the nodes have about the same
number of connections
and we don't have any hubs with very
high connectivity
which one is right depends on the
situation uh it's a very subjective
choice
so we can take a very simple sir model
and spread that out over
this network we'll do a very simple uh
network of just four nodes
linear so we can see what happens the
infection will start in the first node
and then spread to the others uh there's
a function in the notebook here called
distribute model that lets us distribute
the sir model
over our network and we're going to use
m as
the migration rate constant
and
we'll just gloss over some of those
details there
we'll pull the the variables the force
of infection differential equations
and the expression for beta
out of that and define our parameters
these are all the parameters and we'll
set the initial conditions
everybody starts out healthy
in each of the compartments so all the
s's are non-zero
and s1 has been reduced by the some
number of infected people
and then we can model that and then
here's our network this is the simple
sir model and this is the sar model on a
network
here are the transitions just two here a
lot of them here
including all the migration uh between
the compartments
we can make the model graph and this is
generated automatically
from the model description the
differential equations again
things you can see get very complicated
very fast
we can simulate it this is the simple
type of
simple sir model that everybody has seen
a lot in the past and when we do it over
a network
we start out everybody um in you know in
the compartments and then first the the
s1 starts to decrease because they're
getting infected
first and then the infection passes to
the second set of compartments and then
the third and then finally the fourth
and we can look at the aggregate
behavior
here which is just adding everything up
by the health state
and we can see it is qualitatively
different from the simple sir model
that the number of infected people is
spread out over time and it's not
necessarily
a symmetrical infection here in fact
this looks like it's
got a a long tail and here it has a
longer rise it looks like
we can also see that instead of
everybody getting infected here
that some people don't get infected and
because of the the network structure
so clearly we can there are some qual
qualitative effects of the network
on the results um and this is what we
want to see
you know how how important are they
so then doing this on the the network
for italy
again this is the the network we're
going to spread the model we're going to
spread out over the network
um we'll use a hundred nodes just
arbitrarily
and we'll generate uh
the the watts strogatz and the barabasi
albert networks
and these are the two networks we're
going to use we can see we've got
one community here that's connected to
31 others and another one here that's
connected to 23
and these can have some very very big
effects on the results
this takes a while to run so i
pre-loaded it
pre-computed it here will pull out
uh all of the the data we need we can
see that we've got a hund uh
1100 uh variables in the model
uh we'll define our parameters
everything's okay there
in terms of being everything numeric and
then define the initial conditions we'll
run the model
and if we look at the model in detail
these are what the curves look like for
all the individual 100 communities
in in the network uh quite varied um the
watts strogatz one
uh or excuse me the the uh bear basie
albert 1 looks very different
but if we aggregate it and
plot that
then we see we get we get this curve
here we've got
you know the asymptomatic or the um
severely infected
that recovered the the mild and the
asymptomatic we've got three curves for
the
uh infected and quarantined here uh one
for the exposed
and and one for the dead these
susceptible i'm not showing because it's
way off scale
and uh surprisingly the
uh cur the the plots for the
um barabasi albert model
come out looking very similar to this
we can then um look at the results
here and we see that uh
with the the watt strogatz model we have
shifted it a little bit
it it's a little bit lower and it fit it
you know fits our data a little bit
better i didn't actually fit these this
is just the result of distributing the
model over a network
the veribasi albert network though um is
very much the same as the original
uh uh non network model
um the dash curves are right on top of
the
uh the solid curves here so it didn't
change it
um that much and that basically brings
me to the end
um so the the artificial population
sizes led to an unrealistic
uh optimized set of parameter values and
that's what i was trying to
to overcome non-pharmaceutical
interventions can play a crucial role in
the model
in terms of its behavior and the real
trick is trying to mathematically model
what's happening socially within the
population
uh don't get caught up in the details of
trying to model
what the effect of masks are what the
effect of distancing is
it's probably better just to come up
with an effective model that you can
put a few dials on to control its shape
the it's important to have a symptomatic
in the model as well as different levels
of severity
quarantine i think is important because
once people are hospitalized they're not
out circulating
uh and the asymptomatic is again is very
important
um we do have a death due to disease
compartment
and as i said non-pharmaceutical
interventions
uh are very important especially for
this disease here
trying to uh understand what's happening
now while it while it's while it's live
while it's happening
and um we have demonstrated
we can extend the model over a network
um but a lot more work needs to be done
in order to understand
what the effects of the network are and
these are the resources uh my packages
compartmental modeling and epidemiology
modeling
that uses the first one are published on
the cloud you should be able to access
them
and there i've got two well from
community posts
and these are some web resources that
we're using to get the data
and i would like to thank you for your
attention and
we are done exactly on time so
i will take questions at this point
it looks like we've got a few here
already in the chat
okay um yes anton you've been doing
similar work
uh shall i say great minds think alike
uh probably not um great minds often
have very different ideas
and um so your stuff here is posted
uh the links so the other people can see
it
uh yeah you took a very uh systems
type approach i recall from your your
earlier work
uh related to to modeling it in terms of
stocks and
resources and supplies and things like
that
and uh you also included things like
availability of hospital beds in the
model
and trying to come up with a model that
policymakers could use which i think is
a
definitely what we need i'm more focused
on the biology because that's my
interest
uh nicholas
yes germany and sweden very different
outcomes um
uh jan uh brugard is speaking
about uh the the situation in sweden
and his talk is is happening right now i
believe so
that might be good to hop over to that
if you're interested in
in that um and and yes i i really do
uh want to model more countries to see
how things
are are happening there and what we can
learn
from the behavior of the models in terms
of
disease characteristics and population
characteristics as well
uh thank you jorge uh for the compliment
um let's see the graph reflect the town
connectivity
do you mean the connectivity of people
within the town itself or the
connectivity that
of one town to another town
you should be able to unmute yourself
or maybe andy could do that
uh who's asking the question uh i was
asking
uh yorkie replying to his question about
asking if
if the graph shouldn't reflect the town
connectivity and i wasn't sure what he
meant by
by town connectivity okay i'm going to
uh
he's set to speak now so if you'd like
to talk you can
jump in hi
yeah thank you uh
yeah i was wondering uh i was referring
to uh
say the since there's no flights people
move around
basically by roads so the geographical
connectivity of this
essentially the road network
yes yes that that's that's very true and
and one could use a graph of the road
network
uh as your network to distribute the
model and in fact you could even make it
a bit more sophisticated by uh letting
some roads have high traffic and other
roads have low traffic
um as well uh in the united states it
would be interstates connecting things
in england it would be the the m
thoroughfares as opposed to the other
ones and i guess in italy it's
they designate those those highways with
the letter i
i think but yes uh that would be very
important
that would be another way to construct
the model um
but sorry but in in though in that case
doesn't a highway model a highway
network resemble more
why would it resemble a small world
network
isn't like a country like italy mostly
like very uh high connected nodes and a
bunch of very little connected nodes
yes that that could very well be the
case um
i i looked you know i looked at both i
simulated both and we did see different
behavior but it wasn't as different as i
expected it to be which was kind of
surprising
the aggregate behavior the detailed
behavior of the individual
nodes was very different between the two
types of graphs
but the aggregate was not and it could
be because of the size that i used
or the general uh you know that uh there
are some tunable parameters on the
uh barabasi albert one and
uh i just chose one reasonable value for
it and got a graph that looked okay
um but you're right the total
connectivity is very important
um and uh
uh you know there are cities you know
like rome seems to be connected to
everything else
and other small towns would only be
connected to their immediate neighbors
um and and not able to reach in one hop
as it were
uh from rome to venice or or rome to
milan
um but people do do that kind of travel
and so that your network should take
that into account
okay uh seth's question um
okay making the network uh responsive
to the force of infection
um not quite sure what he means by
making
the the network endogenous i think we
did
and that does affect the the overall
force of infection the aggregate
uh but we're still able to model it the
same simple way
at the lower level um
and then seeing what the the emergent
behavior of the whole network would be
rather than trying to model the emergent
behavior
um you know trying to to build that into
the the simpler behavior at the nodes i
think that's what you're getting at
there
but we can talk later afterwards and
that looks like it for the questions and
and thank you for the compliments
everybody
um it's fun work i really like working
with these models
uh the trouble is you you can get
too caught up with your model uh i mean
you think that that's it's reality so
you gotta be careful about that
um you always have to think well what
could i be missing
or what did i put in that really
shouldn't be there
so thank you